Thank you.
Hello, everyone. Welcome to the space. We're waiting for Morgan. We'll get started in a few minutes.
We'll get started in a few minutes.
Morgan, I sent you the co-host invite.
All right, X is telling me that you're not in the space. So I'm not sure exactly what's going on, but hopefully you can find the co-host invite.
I think we all forget that technology is a miracle, but it's kind of frustrating sometimes.
Do you think you can drop out and try coming back in, Morgan?
All right, I'm just having some trouble getting Morgan in as the co-host.
He should be, it should have worked, but I'm going to have to go back, you know, post-production
to remove these early minutes.
All right, yeah, I'm not sure I dropped you.
Yeah, it said you canceled the invitation to be co-host.
So I sent you another invitation to be co-host.
It should be in your inbox and you're just going to click accept co-host invitation.
I don't know why it dropped you and said you canceled the invitation.
The reason this is important is that it's going to drop me at least in time at like a very climactic
moment when I'm in the middle of some rant and then all of a sudden I'm going to get dropped
and Morgan isn't the co-host then and there's going to be no one to keep the space going.
We're booming hard right now, as I like to say.
Alex, welcome.
Miss, welcome.
Blue, welcome.
Bark, welcome.
I saw Margie.
She's out for a minute.
Probably shaking her head at our technological issues before she got recruited to be co-host.
Would anyone else like to be co-host while we figure out how to get Morgan up here?
I don't see any signs.
All right, let me try to send it one more time, Morgan.
So Morgan is accepting the co-host invites and it's not going through.
Perhaps it's better if I end this and start it up again.
I'm not certain if that's going to like screw everything up.
I really don't.
I have no idea.
However, I need a co-host.
So let's give that a try.